[Music]
[Applause]
popular broadcaster inside the nba
analyst hall of famer charles barkley
back on the program good morning chuck
how you doing yo man why you get
only you got me up this early in the day
i'm morning only you
that's how much i like your ass i love
you ass i'll never get up this early in
the morning only because of you
all right well what are you gonna do the
rest of the day
well i'm going to sleep in until that
while i wake up then i'm going to play
golf all day i got the day off
well now that you have a uh a golf swing
here you're looking good
i'm getting better brother getting
better i work hard shout out to my coach
i worked hard and i want some more of
you dan but you know
i want you i look i remind people i'm
one of the last people who saw you play
well
and that was in dayton ohio when you
shot a
79 and you played well
and you should have retired there or
stopped taking lessons
you know what i'm just glad to be out
playing having fun again
smoking me a cup of cigars drinking a
little bit
hey that's not there's only two things
old people can do
golfing fish and i love both of them all
right i got a question for you
i'll give you two pga championships
or one masters what would you rather
have
well i think it'd probably be the
masters because you know
it's just that's you know unless you're
from overseas where they think the open
championship is the greatest thing ever
i think winning the masters with the
tradition in history
i think that i think that would be it
how about
three pga championships or one masters
well i think three three kind of takes
it to a whole another level so i'd go
with three of those
uh but listen winning one masters that's
historical
uh two is different but three i think
that go with three pgas
how about an nba championship
or the masters
well i think the masters personally i
mean because
hey they give about the nba championship
every year
and i know they do the masters every
year but like
nobody knows who won a championship five
years ago in the nba
but you know to be able to host i mean
think about that i think that's such a
great tradition
you know you you talk about places you
want to be can you imagine
being at the master's dinner on tuesday
night with
only guys who won the match and you get
to pick out the menu
that would be one of the coolest things
ever
dan i mean i mean think about that you
get to pick out the menu
and there's probably i don't even know
how many living
masters champions there are it can't be
more than
30. what would your menu be
uh probably fried chicken
uh ham hocks neck bones
kit lens um some type of pecan
uh pecan pie some collard greens
i'd go all i mean you know they ain't
had no chillers or ham hocks and neck
balls there
i might even throw some figures and
pictures
when you go back to alabama do you got a
restaurant or go-to restaurant
i'll go to fleming's every night when
i'm in alabama cause i'm in a small town
and we don't have any restaurants
so i have to drive to birmingham my
hometown leaves we don't have any
restaurants
uh so we i drive i spent every night
when i'm in alabama i go to fleming's uh
they they just take good care of me
there and i take a couple of my homeboys
and we have a great night i saw that you
gave back to your school
you were giving out uh a thousand
dollars to employees at your high school
well you know dan it's been a tough year
um
it's been a tough year
[Music]
in the world so shout out to anybody who
lost somebody to covet or lost their job
and you know and you know i love
teachers i admire them i respect them
and i want to do something nice for the
teachers in my hometown
and i thought it'd be nice to give him a
little year-end bonus i mean because i
know it's been crazy
i couldn't imagine hey it's so funny
i talked to all my friends who got kids
they found out doing this copic
situation
when their kids at home their kids are a
pain in the ass
hey they're like they're like yo man
my kids are crazy having them at the
house all day i'm never gonna say
anything bad about teachers in my life
so
i wanted to give a shout out to all the
teachers out there because everybody
realized during the pandemic
my kid is crazy as hell
what were you like if i talked to one of
your grade school teachers what would
they have said about you
oh i didn't start going crazy until
probably my
second or third year in the nba when i
first got into this whole craziness
i was a really quiet shy kid back in
high school
but you know once you get in the line
like man it's a different animal
and first of all i got a limelight in
philadelphia
i tell people there's nothing can come
there's nothing that can prepare you for
being famous there's nothing in the
world
and then to do it in philadelphia is a
whole nother animal
so uh i i was a good kid i had great
friends and great teachers miss turk
miss hill miss robinson
love y'all miss robinson passed away mrs
turk and miss hill were amazing
uh my coaches wallace honeycutt and
billy copeland were amazing
you know dan i always tell people you
know i watch the news all the time
you see how crazy it is in some of these
big cities
going to growing up in a small town with
a couple of people man i think was a
really
great thing for me because i didn't know
what i was missing but i didn't have to
worry about all that crime and all this
craziness
going around in the country that you see
every day on television
but you said your second year you had
the spotlight on you
like how goofy did it get for you
it's something you can't even explain
you know microphones in your face every
day
guys asking you questions that you know
i'm trying you trying to learn
but are you talking about your social
life like when you went out
and and you know that you were you were
exposed to a big city
yeah and it was crazy i i tell you the
story dan
i think uh at the beginning of my third
year i became a star
and it was overwhelming and this is how
stupid i was
really i got a bunch of many of my guys
together that's your man
it's hard for people walking up to you
all the time or autographs take pictures
let's go somewhere so i can get away and
we can just be
boys and i've never been out of the
country at that point so i said
hey let's go to hawaii for a week nobody
will know me in hawaii
i'll get i'll get like nobody gonna know
me
man that's how crazy it was because like
when people come to people on autographs
some pictures all the time
when it first happens it's a little
overwhelming but i took like four of my
friends we went to hawaii i was like
yeah nobody's gonna know me in hawaii
and that was my first like oh yeah being
in the limelight
is totally different it's totally
different than anything i'm ever gonna
experience
but i i like oh man this is gonna be
weird they know me in hawaii it's crazy
yeah but imagine if you're
michael jordan or tiger woods and like
you know or a big time actor or musician
and you're traveling like you can't go
anywhere
well you know what's interesting i've
been close with michael and tiger
at some point out of all the celebrities
i've ever met in my life and been around
michael and tiger are the only two that
people
absolutely lose their mind when they're
around
like and i listen i've been around
everybody dan to a certain degree
but i will say this michael jordan and
tiger woods are the only two athletes
i've ever been around
where people absolutely lose their mind
when michael was in his heyday and tiger
tiger's always been tiger
those are like those the only two guys
i've ever been around like people get
excited when you're around
other guys but people absolutely when
michael was in his heyday
people and same thing with tiger people
just stop and stare and they think it's
like
it was crazy back it was it was amazing
and crazy
so thank god i never been as big as
either one of those guys
he's uh charles barkley the hall of
famer mclovin give
charles the poll question today okay the
nba one
yeah okay which player has the most
pressure on him in this year's
postseason
uh luca doncic joel embiid nicolo jokic
uh giannis attachment or james harden
well it's an easy question it's either
it's either it's james harden
uh the the the nets uh and kev that nets
got the most pressure
of any team in the nba they have to win
the championship but their season is not
a success
and i said you got to put in paul george
as well
uh that's a fair that's a fair thing uh
but giannis
giannis has to uh giannis and and i'm
telling you something
giannis uh giannis and james harden
and paul george those three guys got the
most pressure
i think that two of those guys got to
get to the finals
i mean listen uh paul george is an
interesting case because i don't think
people look at him like they look at
giannis
or j or or that team they put together
in brooklyn
paul does have some pressure but
like man the west is the craziest i've
ever seen it
i have zero idea who's going to win the
west
but in the east it's easily brooklyn
and milwaukee who are going to play in
the second round of the playoffs
uh but yeah it's brooklyn and milwaukee
both of those teams got to at least get
to the finals
or it's been a disappointing season
you were on espn yesterday with mike
greenberg and it sounded like if
lebron wins another title you might
elevate lebron
above michael jordan you're open to that
i'm open to the discussion okay you know
first of all i think they got a lucky
break having to play the phoenix suns
but if they can win three series if he
beats
phoenix they beat denver
and then they beat the clippers the
caveat to me honestly
uh dan is gonna be if if they can beat
the big three in brooklyn now i'm on i'm
telling you i'm picking milwaukee to win
the east
i love what they've done with drew
holliday and pj tucker
but if lebron can get win three series
on the roads
beat the big three in brooklyn now if he
beats philadelphia or milwaukee
but if he beats those three guys in
brooklyn
i would be open to the discussion that
he is
i would elevate him past kobe and then
i would listen to the argument that he's
in the conversation with michael jordan
i think that's only fair because this to
me
is gonna you know he's been out
basically all season
after the days have been out basically
all season if they can win three series
on the road
and beat the brooklyn nets i'm i'm open
to the conversation that he's
on michael jordan's level but you don't
even have him on kobe's level
i don't i got kobe a little bit ahead of
lebron
just a little bit uh i do
but you know it's so funny when you have
these arguments
hey listen i'm not putting in my head
like when people be artists
you're crazy charles barkley you're
crazy you got kobe bryant ahead of
lebron i said
i don't have papa jones ahead of lebron
i said kobe bryant he's one of the best
to ever do it
and i love popeye but i'm telling you
like you know he's in that conversation
but man
i don't think the lakers are going to
win the championship but if they're able
to win a champions fish ship this year
i think you got to at least be open to
the conversation
we had robert dory on yesterday and
after he got a shout out from rudy
tomjanovich at the hall of fame that he
should be in the hall of fame i asked
robert
if he is a hall of famer what do you
think
you know dan i i don't answer those
questions because i don't want to
poo poo on anybody robert is somebody i
i respect
he had a hell of a career but you know i
i don't i'm just glad number one see
will finally got in he should have been
in five years ago
but i think it's such a tough call to
vote
i don't have a vote but man that's a
very interesting
debate about robert ori he's had a hell
of a career i know he won a lot of
championships
but like i say i'm glad i don't have to
make that vote
would you rather have robert orry's
career carl malone's
car malones carmelo's easy hall of famer
he's on the dream team
listen hey everybody wants to win i
wanna i wanted to win a championship
but you know it's interesting how
guys who get paid to talk about sports
always want a bad mouth guys like myself
carl malone john stockton patrick ewing
you know it's a i don't know how i
became a singular thing
you know it's like you know nobody wins
like wait why y'all picking on not being
picking is not the right word why y'all
pick it on up like we just didn't have
teams that were good enough to win so i
don't understand how it switched from
like
it's a team game and then when you don't
win like was your fault
pretty much my brother it's my fault we
were even that we were
we were on tv you know hey we didn't
listen i'm not i don't i don't and i
don't i don't want to throw shade at
anybody i'm saying
hey we only showed to utah jazz because
of john stockton and call them along
let's get that out the way
we didn't show the jazz because of
thorough bailey and vine russell
hey i love santa balos the reason we
were on tv air week was because of me
because it wasn't because of says
apollos and miguel
night
knight
if you could change anything about that
series against the bulls
in the finals what what would you change
strategy wise
well we had you know we had a six point
lead
and we ran three plays for me and i had
to pass the ball three straight times
i i i lay around sometime and think like
man i should have went through that
double team
it's not a good basketball play it's not
a smart basketball play
but they made me pass the ball three
times in a row and we didn't score
and they scored seven straight points to
beat us by one
sometimes when i'm in my private moments
i'm like
i actually it's so funny you asked me
that question that's like okay
because horace grant and scotty pippen
are the two best defenders
when they dw there's no space because
they're both lean and athletic
it's hard to find actually a passing
angle out of that double team
but sometimes when i'm in a room by
myself i think like
well maybe if i had to be at this but
it's like i say it's not a smart
basketball player to try to go against a
double team especially those two guys
but that's the only thing i i think
about at times then
great question and then don't leave john
john paxton open well
okay so you know it's interesting on the
play
because i had been studying because i
knew we were going to play the bulls in
the finals the year i got treated to
phoenix i told cotton fitzsimmons us
is hey we're going to play the bulls in
the finals
and i've been studying tape on them all
year so to play
because people said charles went for
that steal i went for the steal because
i know nobody else on that teams only
two guys on the team had the courage to
shoot the ball
that was mj and paxton because you go
back and look at the play
scotty actually had a layup and horse
grit had a layup but they didn't want to
shoot the ball
so the play was going to be in my mind i
saw him running
they're going to throw it to scotty and
they were going to have michael coming
at us full
speed so i jump to play
i jump to play because i said scott is
not going to shoot it
nobody's going to shoot so i feel like i
had time to get back in the play
but scotty gave it to her he didn't he
passed it
he he could have took it to the basket
we would have tried to tie it up
horace had a layup it would have tied it
up and i said okay
but i went to jump michael because
michael was going to get it was going to
be a handoff
so i jumped to play and
listen uh danny shouldn't have left
paxton because if they had to score the
two it would have still been a tie game
but hey it is what it is brother but i
have scouted that play for six months
that's you know just the detail it's
pretty amazing
well you know i used to always look at
the tape so when i got traded i said
we're going to play the bulls in the
finals and i said i cannot i got this
we're going to play them and i was very
confident against them
very confident because i know they
couldn't match up with me
we couldn't match up with michael and it
i actually i think the guy who played
great that series would never get better
with scott williams
we he he's the guy who really invite in
my
opinion had a huge effect in that series
but it still came down to to michael
against me and i didn't the only game
i i i didn't play i played i didn't play
good in one but the rest of the series
i played good but uh it was i just
couldn't make enough plays for us to win
go back to bed thanks for joining us uh
great i did dan
i told you i once you're up you can't go
back to bed
you told me you were going back to sleep
and then you were gonna wake up and play
golf
i'm gonna practice that i'm only working
on my game right there why don't you
come to tahoe anymore man
well listen how about this why i want to
lose now
i i would crush you before now it might
be competitive
yeah but why wouldn't you do your show
from tahoe that week you got every job
in the world you can have anybody on
your show you want
lake tahoe is the only place in the
country where it's not gonna be hot
you should do your shirt a whole week
from tahoe and then let me kick your ass
on the golf course
all right it's only may so i got time
well man hey you know i got a lot of
love for you man i'm so happy for all
your success thanks for having me on
brother
thank you charles that's uh the hall of
famer charles barkley